we've come to sunderland's stadium of
light because it's hard to visualize the
magnitude of what has happened
there's no crash site no ground zero but
in the course of nine months
fifty thousand people have lost their
lives to covert 19
enough to fill every chair in this
stadium
and a thousand more this microscopic
killer has
terrorized us it's taken loved ones
before their time
it's disrupted our daily lives so
profoundly
we rarely get a moment to reflect on the
scale of what's happened
that each of these seats and more is an
empty chair
in someone's home the stadium stands in
a city that's had a high case rate
south tyneside and sunderland nhs trust
has reported
over 400 deaths fiona anderson was one
48 years old her family say she
contracted the virus doing what she
loved
nursing her father was also infected and
hospitalized
but he recovered and was discharged the
day before fiona died
her sister sarah says the loss is
immeasurable
for us she died in service she she was
working for her
the health service she was working on
behalf of her country it's been six
months now
um and i still feel
frustrated by everything and by what's
going on in the world but i don't think
i'll ever come to terms to the loss of
my sister
deaths among under 40s have been rare
but still in the hundreds teenagers and
even younger
are among them but it's the elderly and
those with existing health problems
who've had years of their lives stolen
76 year old sylvia griffiths
died in a sunderland care home her
daughter deborah believes the size of
the uk's death toll
could have been avoided it shouldn't
have happened it shouldn't have got to
50
000 we're starting to get this under
control with the lockdown
and here we are yet again what do you
think went wrong
there's various things went wrong lack
of ppe the government guidance wasn't
clear
i think people were confused one one one
the testing system the the track and
trace which clearly hasn't worked
as it was supposed to do we passed this
dreadful milestone in a week that has
given hope
that we may soon have a vaccine and
these seats will be filled once again
and we can celebrate life jason farrell
sky news